so it's a different realm between a man
and a woman so for instance when you see
my guy tyler hero 21 years old right
awesome little basketball player for the
miami heat
just won six man of the year he meets a
hot instagram girl knocks her up he's
having a baby with the girl does that
serve him well is he more focused on the
court now or is his whole career based
on a hot instagram because you gotta
so it's well you're talking about
tens of thousands of years of
evolutionary biology colliding with
current society and current norms which
constantly change and are constantly
updated so these these adjustments are
going to take time we're living through
a transition period right now i think
and that's i think that's what's really
going on anyways we'll see what's going
to happen there by the way at the end of
the day do you think do you think
there's any chance that johnny's going
to play jack sparrow again none
whatsoever disney blew that no no sure
never you really believed 100 million he
said no to